plusieurs régions du pays ont subi des
inondations au cours des dernières
années le Manitoba tout récemment au
printemps le Québec l'Ontario et le
Nouveau-Brunswick en 2019 le Québec est
l'Ontario se remettait d'ailleurs à
peine des inondations de 2017 deux ans
auparavant mais est-ce qu'avec les
changements climatiques ces événements
seront plus fréquents et que peut-on
faire pour mieux s'y préparer j'ai
discuté de ces questions avec Pascal
Biron professeur à l'Université
Concordia
[Musique]
on sent très heureux quand on est face à
une rivière en crue on voit les arbres
qui sont Charriers tout ce que ça peut
transporter une rivière c'est fascinant
d'avoir cette humidité de se dire on
peut pas tout dominer là je pense qu'on
a eu peut-être une certaine arrogance
nous autant de l'humanité par rapport
aux rivières de dire on va les contrôler
on va construire des barrages des digues
on va drainer les milieux humides c'est
nous qui contrôle notre territoire il a
peut-être un retour balancier de 0 à
peut-être pas finalement il faudrait
juste mieux la comprendre
l'hydrogéomorphologie étudie la
dynamique des rivières sur le territoire
notamment où va l'eau lors des
inondations on oublie parce que quand on
voit une rivière qui est pas en
inondation bon elle a une certaine
largeur mais pas tant d'espace que ça
mais c'est de comprendre qu'il y a un
espace autour de cette rivière-là qui
lui appartient finalement en la rivière
c'est elle-même qui l'a créé cet espace
là de les vallées qu'on occupe ont été
créés par l'érosion des rivières alors
c'est un peu normal que de temps en
temps elle veuillent aller récupérer cet
espace là on a tendance à vouloir tout
stabiliser mais se battre contre
l'inévitable un jour la rivière voilà
l'emporter qu'est-ce que c'est le plus
grand défi pour vous et peut-être même
pour nous tous collectivement face aux
inondations
ce qui est compliqué avec les
inondations c'est que on agit à un
moment d'une crise rapidement forcément
nos montres les gens s'entraident
beaucoup tout ça mais assez rapidement
après on a tendance à oublier on a eu
deux inondations très rapprochées dans
sensiblement les mêmes secteurs en 2017
et 2019 et ça ça a vraiment
secouer beaucoup de gens et faire en
sorte que là il y a une volonté il faut
investir il faut faire quelque chose on
peut pas le status quo est pas
acceptable donc pour un gouvernement
c'est plus facile de dire oui on
investit x millions les gens sont
vraiment d'accord avec ces dépenses là
quand les questions des inondations on
se rend compte que l'information la
connaissance pour mieux se protéger
c'est la clé ou c'est vraiment la clé on
a constaté en 2017 quand il est grosses
inondations dans la rivière des
Outaouais notamment que les gens étaient
vraiment mal préparés il y avait
certaines parties où on avait un peu de
cartes de zone inondables d'autres pas
du tout ça m'avait toujours étonné des
autos qui étaient sous l'eau mais ça
c'est pas monter si vite que exactement
ce qu'on a pas pu avertir les gens de
minimalement déplacer leur voiture dans
un endroit plus élevé ce qui est quand
même assez simple
c'est comme si on savait pas qu'il y
avait des inondations un peu en 2017
alors qu'au Québec on était province de
avec beaucoup beaucoup de rivières en
2018 le gouvernement du Québec lance
donc le projet info cru pour mettre
notamment à jour les cartes de zone
inondable pour y arriver on se sert
entre autres de donner leader cette
acronyme anglais fait référence à la
télédétection par laser pour chaque
mètre carré du territoire ces données
fournissent une élévation une
information extrêmement précieuse
ça ça va donner au moins la capacité
d'avoir partout sur le territoire une
connaissance des ongles qui seront pas
personnellement inondées et aussi il y a
un mode qu'on appelle prévisionnel donc
des simulations qui sont rouler à
l'avance ce qui fait que si on nous
annonce dans quelques jours il va avoir
un débit de temps on a déjà une carte
prête les gens peuvent voir ok ça va
c'est secteur là qui vont être inondés
ça va être ça les profondeurs donc on
intervient différemment quand on a cette
information-là qui est assez importante
parce que c'est pas du tout la même
chose d'avoir 10 cm d'eau chez soi qu'un
maintien et demi là où il y a réel
danger pour la sécurité des personnes
avec une approche comme ça c'est
beaucoup moins couteux un infime
fraction du coup que ce serait d'aller
prendre des mesures de terrain partout
dans toutes les rivières du Canada et
de tout temps la rivière Chaudière si
vous parlez aux gens du secteur ces
documenté depuis 18e siècle on était
bien avant les changements climatiques
la nuance avec maintenant c'est
peut-être moins en mesure de prévoir les
extrêmes dans notre climat les
changements climatiques veulent dire
réchauffement ça c'est clair ça veut
dire que l'hiver on peut s'attendre à ce
qu'il y a potentiellement moins de neige
plus de précipitations sous forme de
pluie c'est amplitude là est difficile à
prévoir si on a beaucoup moins de neige
on pourrait imaginer une fonte moins
importante mais par contre ce qu'on
prévoit c'est vraiment une plus grande
variabilité c'est des extrêmes plus
importants à ce moment-là il faut se
préparer à des événements qu'on n'a pas
encore connus c'est ça que le cerveau
humain toujours de la difficulté à
envisager quand on voit des images on
dit ah oui l'eau s'est rendu là je le
comprends mais d'envisager ce que ça
serait si l'autre rendait plus haut
encore
avait une vitesse plus élevée mettons ça
c'est difficile le principe de
précaution c'est qu'avec les changements
climatiques faut prévoir un peu plus de
complexité d'un climat et donc
potentiellement les inondations plus
importantes